John Fortier is the co-author of second
term blues how george w bush has
governed whether co-author is norm
Ornstein in the stir of 40 a how has
george w bush governed well George Bush
has had a tough second term that is not
uncommon with part of the book is to
look at second term presidencies in
general and and many of the problems
that other second term presidents of
that Bush has had them I would say he's
had them in a greater degree he's stuck
in a rut of unpopularity but there are
many many similarities in terms of
presidents who have gotten tired over
time their staffs have turned over
overtime have lost support in Congress
in their party many presidents turn to
foreign policy in a second term and Bush
has found that difficult to do because
the Iraq war is popular and and does not
have another avenue to look for to find
a legacy so I think Bush looks like many
other presidents but his his troubles
are a bit deeper than some of our more
recent second term presidents can you
give us a comparison of a nut to another
president what about President Clinton
well if you think about President
Clinton and President Reagan a couple of
interesting things they they they
bounced around a lot more they were at
times high in popularity and had some
lows and came back and partly they were
able in their second term to really turn
away from some of their domestic
troubles scandals which tend to come up
in a second term or problems with
Congress being in the the other party's
hands which both Reagan and Clinton had
but they were able to look to in
Reagan's case to gains in the Cold War
deals with with the Soviet Union over a
reduction of missiles or in the case of
Clinton in the Irish and Middle East
peace process they were able to sort of
get away from their domestic troubles by
going away and bushes had a harder time
doing that because of his the
unpopularity of the war in Iraq do you
find that President Bush has been
consistent in what he believes in how he
acts well I think Bush has had a hard
time carrying through his style from his
first term I mean his first term was
very successful legislatively in many
ways he talked about how he was a
president who had political capital and
liked to use it and I think the contrast
is with his father his father had been a
popular president after
the first Iraq war and had lost traction
because he didn't have a domestic agenda
and essentially sat on his popularity
Bush said I'm not going to do that I'm
gonna use my popularity in the first
term that really worked did it was
whether winning in the midterm elections
or or winning getting popularity from
after 9/11 or the beginning of the Iraq
war he was able to turn that into
domestic of priorities which he could
get through Congress but there's tax
cuts or the Homeland Security Department
but as his popularity faded in the
second term his own party started adrift
and then certainly the 2006 elections
have changed things radically so it's
it's hard for Bush to use that model
that he governed in the first term in
the second term so I think I saw it
might have been your co-author a quote
from your co-author that everybody is
just waiting for this group to leave
town is there anything legislatively
that's going to happen in the next year
and a half I think it's hard to see you
have very common for second term
presidents not to do so much we're
getting closer to the end and you have a
real clash between the Democratic
Congress their Bush presidency and
you're looking ahead very soon we will
see the Democratic nominee and the
Republican nominee be the focus of both
parties and not the president so I don't
think they're great incentives to work
together occasionally there are across
across parties but I don't think we have
a lot of incentives to work together for
the for the remainder of the term in
second term blues do you have advice for
the president no we don't we don't look
as much ahead as we look at the first
year and it is a compilation of essays
by political scientists and journalists
as well looking at different aspects of
his second term presidency I think it's
it's hard for second term presidents to
avoid their fate and bush because of the
Iraq Wars unpopularity is deeper in it
and I think it's going to be a little
hard for him to turn it around john
Fortier is the co-author of second term
blues how george w bush is governed what
is your day job I'm a fellow the
American Enterprise Institute and I'm
clickable scientist by training thank
you very much